hey guys welcome back to the city
skylines today I'm going to examine my
own mistakes one of those mistakes was
quite frankly putting all my commercial
and all my residential stuff together
because looking at real life cities and
I'm not I don't really want to give any
examples of terrible cities but I'm
Rotterdam you shouldn't really keep them
separate like that because I still have
this problem where I still have a demand
for commercial zones and all of my
commercial zones are jobless and don't
have any customers because the
commercial zones are so far away from
all the residential zones and it's not
really working very well so that is one
issue I have one mistake that I also
made in the view in the in future holy
[ __ ] as a terrible power locks in the
past is using OBS to record because I
gave it a shot I gave it a shot and I'm
never going to do that again it was not
that bad I mean the resolution was okay
and it was laggy but then again this is
a time lapse but the resolution was
nowhere as good as with fraps of course
because France master race so I'm going
to use that from now on and this road by
the way it might look very stupid but I
had this idea that I might be able to
actually use to two lane roads that have
one direction and combine them to make
one four lane road that doesn't create
as much noise pollution but also does it
create any traffic lights but then the
issue that was that soon arose was how
do you get from one side of the road to
the other so I decided to add
intersections every here and then and
that didn't work at all it only created
the stupidness and the biggest issue
with this road is it was so perfect in
my head and then I opened this road and
it turns out that all of the users of
course in this game are so incredibly
stupid that they don't even know how
those things work at least that's what I
thought but then I realized that having
two roads that only go in one direction
does mean that people are going to have
to drive all the way to the end of the
road to find the nearest intersection
that that is actually further away from
the road they actually want to be from
so that then after that they can drive
back and get into the
area if you understand what I mean
basically it meant that cars had to
drive all over this road and go till the
end of the world and back to just to get
to their house at the beginning of the
road and that was a huge issue so at
some point I did fix that issue with
this road and i must say that even
though it's not that efficient in terms
of how far people have to drive I don't
give a [ __ ] because so far it's really
good at not piling up cars so I suppose
I'm kind of happy about that but the the
separates two lane road kind of main
road doesn't work nearly as good as the
one main highway road because that is
definitely an awesome invention and
something that many more people should
use because highways as in the ramps
work really well as standalone highways
that go to a different town or something
like that without um yeah spending too
much money or a space on that it's
actually very efficient so that's nice
and at this point I was trying to get
this road to go to the top of the hill
because I was planning my newest great
neighborhood over here which would soon
be called Rome for no reason and that
didn't really work out because the
terraforming wasn't all that great and
this this area started out as a great
idea with that four-lane road aside from
having the traffic lights of course so
at some point I was like no this is not
going to happen i'm going to downgrade
this four-lane road because i went to
get rid of almost those traffic lights
but then it turns out that this was
going to be a huge and busy area and i
got some congestion in this area later
on it's definitely not read all the time
and it's only in a couple of spots but
it it you kind of want your entire city
to look green and i don't know if that's
just me but that's some kind of well
mental thing that I have going that I
don't want any roads to be red so the
more roads i built the more roads are
going to be red and the more I get
annoyed by that even though of course
that does mean that more roads are also
going to be green but yeah here you can
see by the way all of the cars piling up
just to get to that little road at the
end of this road so they could go back
so I figured you know I'm going to amp
this stupid
round things so that people can actually
go back without having any intersections
and though I must say it really does
work and like I said there's barely any
congestion in this area it is completely
stupid and expensive so it is definitely
not the best way to fix this problem of
having congestion but I had the mindset
of I would rather have enormous ramps
and flying cars than congestion in my
city so anything above traffic jams that
is basically my mind state at that point
and this neighborhood which would soon
become a part of vancouver and vancouver
would buy that turn into a huge area
within the city is just an area that i
built because i had three demands but I
was like I want more population so I'm
going to just build as much residential
as I can as well as adding more
commercial and possibly more industrial
because I was hoping to get a huge
population boost and what go and then go
to the 48,000 people in my city and get
the next Lancelot but it didn't really
work like that things really rarely seem
to actually work like you plant them to
in this game which is a great thing
because that is that is definitely how
real life works nothing really works as
you plan it it's not like SimCity where
you can just say okay I am just going to
be able to [ __ ] on of buildings now and
that means that miking my population is
going to grow no you actually have to
keep your current population happy and
provide the right services and keep the
demands in check and things like that so
there's some something to at least
something to keep in mind and this area
I have no idea I'm late I'm later on
calling this area kufstein which I will
elaborate on further but it's called
that because I figured that this would
be a cool mountain area but then as soon
as I started building houses on top of
that and I got some apartment buildings
in the main area of Vancouver it turned
out that that one small hill over there
wasn't really all that big as I thought
it was but really just a small hill so
it never turned into a really awesome
kind of on the mountains village as I
expected it to be but it was pretty cool
nonetheless that's something that I'm
not too much a panel and I don't know if
you can actually terraform the rocks and
stuff like that but so far that doesn't
seem to be the case then as soon as you
get a steep slope it's going to turn
into rocks and you can't really have a
steep grassy slope it seems and you
can't also have multiple types of rocks
it's just okay and that slope is that
sleep that's going to be rocks and that
is not steep that scum the grass and
even though you have really steep grassy
slopes and sometimes you also want to
have a summit on top of a mountain that
it consists out of rocks but it's still
somewhat flat because right now you also
have these big mountains and on top of
them they have like a small grants land
which doesn't make too much seem to make
too much sense either but you know
that's just small things and recently a
patch did come out and that is really
fast from the initial release and I'm
really happy about that because that
really shows how involved they are even
uttered they just released the game
because now you can actually upgrade
roads I mean you can actually change the
direction of 19 roads and upgrade
one-lane roads to two lane roads and
vice versa which was something you
didn't have in the game before and i was
using mots for at some point but now we
can do that in a game so that is really
awesome as well as some small bug fixes
and possibly some other things that I
probably forgot but I'll see that in the
future anyway and oh yeah that was a
lamp on your map I wasn't too happy
about the land value in the city by the
way because I kind of wanted the land
value to be a bit higher but all those
four-lane roads create so much noise
pollution that within the well certain
radius from the four-lane roads you're
not gonna have a good land value anyway
so not not really too happy about that
but then again the land for you doesn't
seem to matter too much because even
with a relatively not that high land
value especially around those four-lane
roads in the downtown
yeah I still got very high level
buildings so it also comes down to
services and generally how big your
population is it seems so it's not
really a worry of me but I'm kind of
used to trying to get as much of a land
value as I can oh wait that reminds me
that was one very important boat fixed
which is game-changing and I'm gonna
implement some in episode 13 I think
because right now that is I think the
next episode that I will record as I'm
talking about this right now so that is
how big the delay still is but the bug
fix that I'm so happy about they finally
fixed the fact that parks make the
commercial demand a lot lower because in
the past parks would actually lower the
commercial demand so much done if you
only had a couple parks in your city and
you had a moderately small sized city
your commercial demand would be nearly
zero and you had no chances of actually
getting commercial demand which is the
problem that I had in the beginning of
playing this game but right now that's
been fixed so that is a really awesome
and positive thing and as soon as I get
my hands on that which will be in about
episode 13 or 14 I can't really remember
exactly but from that moment on I'm
probably going to spam many parks around
in my city because that's something I
want and I might at some point actually
decide to remove by that downgrade the
four-lane roads because they cause new
noise pollution and it seems like some
of them aren't really necessary and this
by the way is just me trying to replace
all of my power plants with solar power
plants because thats that's green and
more efficient and actually more cheap
than the windmills i had earlier on but
yeah that's it for this episode so thank
you for watching and I'll see you on the
next one